hybrid cloud is one of the most common
architectural patterns out there
but it's generally actually the result
of companies that are unable to abandon
an existing technology stack
in favor of the public cloud but what if
i told you you could get the best of
both worlds the innovation
and cutting edge technologies made
possible through public cloud providers
and at the same time having the
flexibility and freedom of running your
assets where you choose to
whether it's on-prem or edge today let's
talk about distributed cloud and the key
benefits that it offers
now i want to start with what a general
hybrid cloud architecture
looks like so you're going to have
customers that are running things on
on-prem environments
maybe they're running things on public
cloud environments
or even private clouds or even addition
we might have edge
environments now
managing all of these environments comes
with their own set of ops teams
challenges data locality latency
concerns
basically all of them will require some
overhead to maintain
distributed cloud comes in right at the
center
essentially what you'll have is a public
cloud
sitting right at the center that's able
to manage
all of those other environments
essentially it extends the capabilities
of a public cloud
to other capabilities now i think
gardner put it best when they said
that in a report that they recently
published they said
that distributed cloud fixes what hybrid
cloud
breaks now today i want to cover four
major themes that generally correspond
with what distributed cloud aims to
solve
and these actually happen to line up
with where hybrid cloud tends to fall
short
now the first one that i want to start
with is consistency
now as i go through the example today
i'm going to put on a number of
different hats
whether i'm dev ops or security and i
want to start with an ops engineer
because an ops engineer we're generally
will generally have to be kind of
interfacing with a distributed cloud
environment
and that's where they will generally
start so as an ops engineer
let's say that one of the first things
that i want to do
is work with a cloud environment so
what i want to do is go to a public
cloud
and in that environment let's say that i
want to create
a kubernetes or even an openshift
cluster
so basically a way to manage
and orchestrate cloud-based applications
now in this process of creating an
openshift cluster
i'm probably given an option at one
point to choose where do i want this
cluster to live
so here's where i'm given a few choices
so maybe i want to do it in a public
cloud location
so let's say for example somewhere like
dallas
or london but
through a distributed cloud i can
register with the public cloud
other locations so maybe somewhere like
an on-prem or edge location
so let's say i've got an on-prem
location in bangalore
or an edge location
in morocco so basically what we've got
here
is whether it's public on-prem or edge
locations
we can choose one of those capabilities
in
directly in my public cloud ui and
dashboard
that's what a distributed cloud will
generally offer
so through this process i'm now able to
deploy
openshift container platform clusters
in three different regions let's say
so we've got three different ocp
clusters we'll say one of them is in
public
we'll say one of them is in edge
and we'll say the last one is on-prem
okay so we've got that kind of situated
from an ops engineering perspective
i'm able to create and manage clusters
across the board
whether they're in any of these general
hybrid cloud style
environments now as an ops engineer that
might be good for day one but for day
two
i need additional capabilities let's say
that i want to do something like
scaling up and down well that's one of
the key advantages of a cloud
is the elasticity so let's say i can
scale up and down
in addition let's say i want my clusters
to be able to network and interface with
one another basically communicate
my applications communicating across the
board so maybe i want to take advantage
of a service mesh capability
that's something a distributed cloud can
offer so
taking a look at that we can start doing
some service meshing capabilities
okay so now that we've got that
groundwork laid out we've covered how
basically for an ops engineer i have a
consistent
experience for deploying clusters in any
of these locations
you have consistency next up
let's talk about devops
so we've covered a bit of devops already
so with the ops perspective of deploying
and managing clusters
but for developers who want to utilize
capabilities generally available in
public clouds
well i have a different angle of
approach here
so putting on my hat as a dev
now let's say one of the first things
that i want to do here
is create a service right so
generally with ocp most devops
capabilities are handled it's a really
good platform for being able to work
with containers
and kind of deploying apps but let's say
i want to take advantage of a service
that cloud providers generally provide
so this would be something like a
database
so i want to create a db so i'm in my
cloud provider
i'm in the dashboard and i want to
create a database
and i'm given a similar option i'm asked
where do you want to create it and some
given options like before
data centers or locations not just
public cloud but also on-prem or edge
and i can choose to deploy those
high-value capabilities
you know so i can decide to deploy a
database in my public cloud
well this is nothing special i've been
able to do that or i should be able to
deploy a database
in addition into edge environments
so that's taken care of as well
so now that we've gotten that piece kind
of squared away
we've kind of talked about how
distributed cloud enables
devops to be more efficient one other
thing i want to use this example for
here
it's innovation and this is for high
value services
so let's say i want to do ai or machine
learning capabilities
something that a public cloud will
generally offer so you know let's say i
have some ai or mlk
capabilities that i want to deploy well
same as before
i can take those capabilities and deploy
them to any of these
environments so with distributed cloud
you're able to innovate
with capabilities generally only
available in public cloud
in environments outside of the public
cloud it's one of the key capabilities
the last one i want to talk about today
is governance
now governance is a key requirement for
pretty much all companies but especially
you know financial institutions or
health or insurance companies
basically concerns like data regulations
compliance data locality
how can a security admin effectively and
with a single control plane
manage policies across the board well
time to put on my last hat here let's
say that i'm a security admin
and i've created a network policy
so this network policy let's say that it
handles things like rbac
or network policies across the board or
security policies
and i want to deploy them to clusters
everywhere in my business
not just in the cloud but also on prem
and edge
well with the distributed cloud you can
do exactly that
by taking advantage of the capabilities
made available i can deploy these
policies
across the board to any of these
environments now this is a simple
example
but it goes to show you how distributed
cloud is tackling problems
that hybrid cloud generally runs into
thanks for joining me for this quick
overview of distributed cloud
if you've enjoyed this video and you
want to see more like this in the future
be sure to drop a like or a comment
below
to see what ibm is doing in the
distributed cloud space be sure to check
out ibm cloud satellite
thank you for watching